[Applaudissements]
gentleman
excellente
pour moi un souvenir d'un grand canadien
qui avait marqué notre Histoire
15 ans
de vie
et bien sûr au dessus il y a peut-être
un contribution au Canada
il a été marin ingénieur astronaute et
finalement politicien Marc Arnaud a
annoncé la semaine dernière qu'il avait
décidé de mettre un terme à sa troisième
carrière pour une retraite amplement
méritée qu'il souhaite consacrer à sa
famille à ses mémoires et à voyager
aussi le député libéral de Notre-Dame de
Grâce ouestman garde de beaux souvenirs
des 14 dernières années même si l'admet
que certains moments ont été plus
difficiles je l'ai rencontré à son
bureau
margarno bonjour merci d'être avec nous
bonjour Daniel le plaisir de vous
accueillir dans mon bureau dernière fois
dans ce bureau comment c'était cette
semaine vous avez parlé de fébrilité
commencez d'annoncer à ses pairs à ses
collègues c'est fini on tourne la base
c'est un moment très émotionnel parce
que certains que j'ai connu depuis 14
ans je liquide et puis sinon seulement
la fin de ma carrière politique mais en
fait je peux dire un certain sens la fin
de ma vie professionnelle parce que j'ai
pas une autre chose devant moi la
troisième la troisième c'est vrai
pourquoi maintenant pourquoi pas
attendre la fin du mandat parce que j'ai
fait une promesse à ma famille l'automne
dernier eux voulaient que je prenne ma
retraite j'avais toujours j'ai toujours
ma bonne santé il voulait profiter que
je sois à la maison plus souvent et je
leur ai dit oui je vais quitter mais si
je peux le faire après avoir soumis le
rapport de l'aide médicale à mourir
j'étais sur ce comité là je voulais le
le soumettre ou Parlement ce que j'ai
fait le 15 février alors maintenant
c'est le temps de partir il y a déjà la
dernière semaine dernière qui ont fait
le lien entre la prise de position que
vous aviez adopté au Comité sur les
langues officielles vous avez dit
vous avez défendu les intérêts des
enveloppes québécois un peu vous êtes
inscrit en faux avec la position du
gouvernement et est-ce qu'il y a un lien
la raison pourquoi je quitte c'est parce
que j'ai fait cette promesse l'automne
dernier mais avant de partir il faut
quand même faire ça job et j'ai pris une
position que moi je considère une
position de principe sur et je sais que
c'est pas la même position que le
gouvernement avait proposé et que
l'opposition voulait mais c'était une
position de principe parce que j'y crois
faire vraiment il faut que je fasse ma
job jusqu'à la dernière journée
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé des
critiques à ce moment-là il y a des gens
qui vous ont dit
qui vous ont même accusés de mes de
mépriser le Québec à cause de cette
position j'ai été accusé de mépriser le
Québec d'être vendu d'être un angryphone
d'être un colonisé
les attaques ont été très très fortes et
puis moi qui suis un fier québécois une
personne qui veut protéger le français
une personne qui reconnaît que le
français la langue officielle du Québec
une personne qui a été la première à
proposer la reconnaissance de la nation
québécoise en 2006 c'est moi qui a été
le premier
ça m'a fait mal on a aussi on s'est
aussi demandé la semaine dernière si
votre absence du Conseil des ministres
vous avez été exclu du Conseil des
ministres par Monsieur Trudeau après
l'élection 2000 de 2021 est-ce que ça ça
a joué dans la balance non
la réalité c'est que j'avais promis
ma famille après l'érection de 2019 que
je quitterai la politique que je me
présenterai pas à la prochaine élection
par contre ce qui est arrivé en 2021
c'est que le premier ministre m'a nommé
ministre des Affaires étrangères j'ai
seulement été là pendant 7 mois avant
que l'élection de 2021 soit déclenchée
alors j'ai reparlé avec ma famille je
leur ai dit écouté ça fait seulement 7
mois que je suis là il y a tellement de
choses qu'on devrait faire et jeter le
quatrième ministre en 5 ans et demi
j'aimerais continuer mais je vous
promets que c'est mon dernier mandat
je ne savais pas que je serais exclu à
ce moment-là et j'ai décidé de rester
parce que il y avait quand même des
choses qu'on m'avait demandé de faire
comme avec le président du comité sur
les affaires autochtones et le président
sur la question de l'aide médicale à
mourir ou président alors j'ai accepté
ces deux rôles mais j'ai complété le
deuxième et j'ai décidé que c'était un
moment logique pour moi de quitter les
hauts faits de votre carrière politique
les moments dont vous allez vous
souvenir quels sont-ils je pense que
c'est les 5 ans et deux mois que j'ai eu
la chance d'être à Transport Canada
parce que c'est rare qu'une personne
qu'un ministre reste dans un poste pour
une longue période comme ça et puis
c'est un ministère que j'ai adoré et où
je pense que nous avons réalisé des
choses importantes c'est peut-être
invisible pour la population
généralement mais l'efficacité de notre
système de transport et sa sécurité sont
des éléments extrêmement importants que
ce soit les trains les avions les
bateaux et puis je suis très fier
d'avoir contribué de ce côté là en
mentionnant début d'entrevue c'est votre
troisième carrière vous avez été dans
l'espace tout le monde aussi vous étiez
dans la marine avant ça laquelle des
trois carrières est la plus agréable ou
plus
de laquelle allez-vous garder le
meilleur souvenir ils sont toutes des
cailloux incroyables mon premier rêve
dans ma vie c'était d'aller dans la
marine j'étais très content mais
probablement celle qui m'a marqué le
plus c'est ma carrière spéciale et puis
mais il y a des moments tellement
mémorables dans les 14 dernières années
que et j'ai fait tellement de bons amis
j'ai appris des choses quand j'étais à
son autre tout le monde disons
apprécié ou était très très gentil
envers moi quand on rentre dans la reine
politique par contre il faut être prêt
pour le fait qu'on va se faire crédit il
y a des gens qui vont vous aimer il y a
des gens qui vous aimeront pas et
absolument vous l'avez dit diplom bah il
y a des gens qui vont maïs en fait des
fois les les émotions sont très très
fortes alors ça ça a été un changement
celui-là je l'ai appris quand j'ai perdu
la première fois dans votre soulage en
2006 que WoW il y a des gens qui ont des
émotions très fortes contre moi et puis
est-ce que je suis prêt à accepter ça
dans la vie politique c'est quelque
chose que tous les policiers doivent
décider s'ils sont prêts à accepter ces
critiques là c'est pas facile est-ce que
c'est devenu trop partisan la Chambre
des communes moi je les dis dans mon
message qu'il faudrait être plus digne
il faut être moins partisan ça ne veut
pas dire qu'on ne critique pas on a
différentes façons de voir les choses
c'est parfaitement acceptable de dire
pourquoi on n'est pas d'accord avec
quelque chose mais on n'est pas obligé
de crier on n'est pas obligé de de
parler pendant quelqu'un est en train de
poser une question ou répondre à une
question alors cet esprit de
courtoisie je pense que il y a une
certaine érosion dans les derniers dans
les dernières années
et moi aussi j'ai parfois je me suis
emporté mais moins souvent que qu'au
début un petit rappel à l'autre quelle
est la suite des choses pour Marc
Garnaud maintenant alors j'ai je n'ai
rien devant moi sauf le fait que je
complète mes mémoires et puis c'est
quelque chose que j'ai décidé de faire
il y a deux ans libres dans mes temps
libre avant que j'oublie et puis alors
ça c'est ma priorité numéro 1
deuxièmement de passer du temps avec ma
famille on va voyager on va simplement
prendre le temps de respirer alors rien
de d'officiel devant moi maganou merci
infiniment bonne retraite merci beaucoup
Daniel le plaisir